chers amis chers et demi rue on se
retrouve son interview portrait
aujourd'hui brigitte fontaine à
l'occasion de son concert au bataclan
bonsoir donc aussi mignon comment ça va
alors on dit on parle il se la pète
beaucoup cité hier on dit en parlant de
vos brigitte fontaine que vous êtes une
icône évidemment s'il vous plaît pas
beaucoup je ne fais pas une ni deux je
suis une unique cannes c'est vrai que
vous êtes en plus pas immobile sur scène
donc icône on dit que vous êtes une
chanteuse sculpte ça vous ennuie aussi
parce que vous trouvez ça trop pdi terre
et où préféreriez finalement séduire le
grand public
ben c'est ce qui est en train de se
produire
oui c'est ce qui est en train de
s'imposer on dit que vous êtes folle
vous êtes loin d'être folle
je suis simplement avec différentes moi
c'est tout
la visite à la folie c'est dangereux
c'est terrible tu ne voudrais pouvoir
ouais en effet grave est terrible voilà
enfin bon s'il veut le dire que c'est
faux lac est non je suis simplement un
peu différente des autres voilà vous
voyez la
planète
rouge et noir comme ça c'est beau à
l'image suis sûr noir océan noir et oui
on doit être pauvre doit être assez bien
tous deux alors votre look surprendre
certains il fait même peur josé artur
j'aurais jamais jamais si si c'est si la
ligne votre look lui faisait peur
maintenant rien ne nous fait peur et
l'huile et
il peut pas il se plante jamais
magnifique il est parfait alors donc on
va faire un petit peu de promotion
brigitte fontaine c'est ici pour la
sortie de votre nouveau single le
troisième single extrait de votre nouvel
album qui s'appelle kékéland 1 et ça
s'intitule pipo et le gros tube du
disque 1 c'est l'amour c'est du pipeau
seront pour les gogos ça c'est
l'amour c'est du pipeau
c'est bon pour les gogos bah voilà rien
à dire c'est définitif dans est en
tournée jusqu'en octobre
en france et le 16 mai mesdames et
messieurs le 16 mai au bataclan brigitte
fontaine oui je remets sert kara le
caureq c'était hyper complet en a raté
genre 3000 personnes
dommage mais le batave c'est bien aussi
un oui moi j'aime beaucoup parce que les
gens aiment beaucoup mais pas seulement
pour moi parce que c'est
on est debout tout le monde est là sa
musique ils sont tous d un bar au fond
par les piccolos bien on danse un peu on
écoute
le fond parfait donc c'est le 16 mai
mesdames messieurs notez le bien sûr vos
petits agents de la voilà alors qu'ils
landes gros succès un déjà plus de cent
mille exemplaires vendus vous êtes un
disque d'or donc comme on dit dans le
métier alors vous expliquer qu est ce qu
un kéké
kéké c'est un être adorable mais nous
fout
allumé
gentille et celui dressé probablement
sur la tête ou les filles aussi
un peu est beau il fait nuit qu'est-ce
que vous êtes des exemples de keke de
gens dont vous pourriez dire ce sont de
vrais kéké
non violence et risque est un vrai que
matthieu chedid aussi matthieu chedid m
dames un temps sec et authentique 1 à la
tv il ya pas trop de calculs
alors vous trouvez toujours avec areski
belkacem est oui sur ce disque il est là
le meilleur de france voilà et vous avez
travaillez beaucoup avec higelin on en
parle et on va voir la place que ces
deux hommes ont tenu dans votre vie on
va parler un peu de votre vie on va
raconter un petit peu votre vie vous
rendez connu non sinon le présent et
c'est tout ce que vous aviez très
intéressante n'importe quoi non mais
bien votre c'est le passé crasseux non
pas du tout justement ce débat vous êtes
né à morlaix dans le nord delà de la
bretagne
oui oui c'est beau et vous étiez vise
les corsaires parti xavier 14 ans et
quand vous êtes revenu à mort les avant
d'enregistrer kékéland on est revenu à
morlaix ils avaient tous vos amoureux
qui vous et même les toits qu'il
attendait à la gare c'est pas beau ça
c'est hyper romantique arrêté
oui et alors vous avez écrit kékéland
air dans un petit hôtel en bretagne
finalement ses fidèles à frêche d'ado
racines mal à freiner alors vos parents
étaient instituteurs
ancré dans la laïcité dans l'anti
cléricalisme c'est votre grand mère
c'est incroyable cette grand-mère
qu'était la retraite elle faisait 2 km
de plus pour les chez l'épicier parce
que l'épicier qui était à côté de chez
elle avait mis ses gosses et les curés
oui et mon arrière grand père était
également un système laïque vous êtes
vraiment une enfant de laïcs l'ordre
première passion c'était le théâtre vous
commencé très jeune à venir des pièces
et à monter des troupes d'amateurs et
vous avez été repérés temps de quoi vous
avez vraiment déjà très jeune quelque
chose à l'âge de 12 ans vous êtes repéré
par un directeur de troupe leçons
dramatiques de l'ouest j'adorerais
petite merveille ouais ça s'est pas fait
on va vous demander à mes parents mes
parents oui de
de m'avoir quand j'aurai 16 ans non
seulement ils ont refusé mais ils ne
m'ont rien dit ce terrible ça vous
aurait donné confiance on s'aimerait
permis d'éviter ne laissait enfin ça
m'aurait permis de faire la vie dont je
n'osais même pas rêver et sa mort évite
et plein plein de galère à paris aurait
en tous les cas dès cette époque vous
saviez que vous écririez que vous feriez
du théâtre savait pas encore à l'époque
que vous changeriez exactement vous
saviez déjà vous êtes une artiste
exactement mais je vous confirme que la
chose qui m'a scandalisé la première
fois que je suis allé à l'école ouais
c'est qu'on n'avait pas le droit de
chanter plus que moi j'arrivais vie tout
à fait normalement te met à chanter et
20 n'ont fait pas un bon sur quelle
école alors une adolescence à ces
révoltés on peut dire rebel rebel envers
vos parents vers la société alors vous
passiez d après midi je vois très bien
moi en train de lire des livres
dostoïevski avec les volets fermés les
bougies allumées comme ça
c'est vrai c'est vrai on vous voit très
bien à l'époque
alors votre premier choc musical c'est
gainsbourg et vous dites que c'est le
plus grand c'est vraiment j'ai qu'ils à
qui vous a marqué les buts ivement ouais
ouais l'écran et voir au début des
années 60 bac en poche vous débarquez à
paris bien décidé à monter sur scène et
en fait ce qui s'est passé que j'ai fait
est-ce que c'est oui mais ce qui s'est
passé c'est qu'à l'époque vous aviez un
mec au début la celui qui avait un mec
un mètre 98 15 ans de plus que vous oui
un code peut dire la vérité 1 1 il avait
une emprise sur voûté
l'emprise c'est ça hein et lady jaloux
je m'en fous des partenaires masculins
et ce connard me demande non on exige
que je renonce à mon doute meti qui dit
que ça avec leurs parents et moi comme
une [ __ ] aussi un jeu j'obtempère
mais oui c'est là que j'ai commencé
acheté voilà par ruse c'est-à-dire
sournoisement ces criminels vous dit tu
veux pas que je fasse deux là s'aiment
c'est pas grave vous êtes passé comme ça
un peu à part russe pour rester dans le
monde du spectacle we dare long du
spectacle
et puis le côté les jours et surtout qui
se passe une petite cérémonie tous les
soirs si sa montre et
voilà alors finalement donc
vous commencez vous commencé à chanter
vous avez dans des boîtes à la rive
gauche et beuglant
bail avec sa femme
bekwai la rose rouge rude règne avec
quoi comme ça
mais ici tout ce qu'ils avaient pu hélas
il un soir vous rencontrez vous le
rencontrez 40 entre l autre il vient
voir là où je chantais et il me proposa
de
comme nous fassions une pièce ensemble
voilà avec fish alors là c'est poker
vous avez encore peur du mec là le grand
là d'un mètre 98
j'étais terrorisée moi je suis là parce
que je suis jeune exégètes de votre vie
ouais et alors donc vous vous continuez
donc le théâtre évidemment puisque
l'autre était plus là et avec higelin et
rufus oui rires fusent sur le savoir
qu'ils étaient internes dans les
hôpitaux de rouen exactement un tous les
trois vous écrivez vous monter une pièce
qui était un énorme succès oui maman
chance énorme énorme succès parce que
tout commence là en fait et vous laissez
pisser à jouer ensuite au théâtre des
champs elysées oui et vous partez en
tournée pendant un an en france quoi
c'est pas vrai et même en autriche un
gros succès un hilarant 65 jacques
canetti dans faut dire qu'il jacques
canetti dans ce sens this way jacques
canetti découvreur de brel de brassens
de tabac à tout le monde créateur des
trois baudets
il s'intéresse à vous ça c'était avant
ouais c'était avant oui mais s'intéresse
aux nerfs quand même une petite erreur
c'était avant avant quoi avons mangé par
adacore avant maman j'ai peur et il vous
fait quoi jacques halitim je me fais
enregistrés et pensant là dessus parce
que le disque est à jeter à la poubelle
je le dis fermement à quiconque aurait
envie d'acheter ses 10 ans il sait pas
comment il s'appelle donc
douze chansons d'avant le déluge ou un
truc comme ça et toujours tendre envers
une chanson d'après le déluge serait
selon sana bref il faut jeter ça à
laquelle très bien ce qu'il en est
autrement de lâcheté par une forte faut
bien commencer d'accord mais c'est
vraiment celui qui est sorti en 68 qui
s'appelle brigitte fontaine est folle
vous le recommander ou non ça va à part
le titre que je n'ai pas choisi ouais
oui on sent que meyssan fou c'est club
house annonce n'est pas le procès des
chaînes arabes les saisies alors là vous
rencontrez areski belkacem donc été
longtemps après les régiments de la gym
voilà et lorsque très marrant de votre
histoire avec lui c'est qu'au départ
bosser avec lui pendant pratiquement je
prends comme un damné et trois en un
voilà trois ans rien rien on était très
bons amis et on travaille et je veux
c'est deux ou trois ans rien et
subitement coup de foudre terrific
d'après c'est du
passé au bout de trois ans comme en un
seul coup vous pouvez voir le coup
double envoyé depuis trois ans oui bah
je sais pas ça tout s'est mis à chauffer
à chauffer à chauffer puis passion
pression patiente à sion et ça dure
encore ça dure encore vous dites c'est
mon compositeur préféré en france et je
vais pas me priver parce que c'est mon
mari l'a donc vous continuer à bosser
avec lui ça se passe très bien alors le
trio higelin rezki fontaine a beaucoup
de succès alors je vais citer trois
chansons en aurez plein qu'on pourrait
citer m'enfin moi je parle de cet outil
qui m'ont marqué cet enfant que je
t'avais fait
magnifique chanson un lettre à monsieur
le chef de gare de latour de carol oui
là c'est moi qui aime beaucoup cette
année ce qui est déjà un qui joue avec
et comme à la radio
comme à la radio oui mais pas jacques
n'est pas la région et puis un jour le
trio donc
fontaine jeunesse qui se sépare parce
qu'un jour vous en avez marre de de la
place qu'ils ont l'un prend sur scène
il était un peu énervant je suis parti
en plein milieu une fois du spectacle
vous allez traverser la
d 110 là j'ai pris mes bagages j'ai
traversé la seine j'ai traversé la salle
j'ai pas revenu sur une moto je pars ah
non non non c'est là notre cousin est
bien plus rentable non mais là c'était
bien parce que nous faisons face à
christian à peu près improvisé oui oui
oui donc je vais tout le monde a cru que
ça faisait partie du spectacle c'est
demain soir où les gens ont compris que
vous étiez vraiment parti pour
partir au bout d'un quart d'heure donc
la boule à thé après à jacques joly est
conseillé vraiment de faire sa une un
truc tout seul ouais et de prendre tout
le truc et surtout de faire du
rock'n'roll voilà que je savais qu'il
aimait ça voilà ça lui a bien réussi pas
mal pas mal
et alors là vous entraînez vous entrez
dans un exil volontaire c'est à dire que
vraiment vous c'est vous qui vous quitte
à
sucre au schéma
improvisé à peu près complètement un
setter mois et à risquer
moins pendant un certain temps après bon
en exil oui c'est à dire nous avons joué
une pièce de théâtre que j'avais écrite
areski belkacem et moi
on aimait beaucoup beaucoup on a fait
des tournées dans toute la france et à
l'étranger un peu et puis en même temps
j'ai passé que c'est niox et sa non non
non quoi va c'est quoi la piaule non non
ça s'appelle quand on l'a joué elle
s'appelait acte ii et on livre édité
elle s'appelle la conciliabules
alors bon ensuite vous disparaissez un
petit peu du dîner sacré délivrer ou
bien entendu beaucoup de livres et alors
vous revenez ccc etienne daho qui vous a
permis de vous annoncer les japonais ah
oui oui les japonais qui ont absolument
voulu produire un disque qui surtout va
absolument voulu que je fasse une
tournée au japon ce qui me plaisait pas
car j'aime pas trop les avions pourquoi
parce qu'on ne peut pas fumer
taxe exceptionnelle vous ayez droit de
fumer
c'est à dire une personne à droite je ne
veux plus jamais fumé ouais nulle part
et à partir du mois de juin tout le
monde à tout le monde de se révolter car
partir du mois de juin
ici en france on ne peut plus fumer dans
les traces abrutis nous retrouver mon
vieux on va faire un grand pas vers
l'adhésion
non c'est vrai ça c'est une honte mais
oui c'est vrai ah bah dis donc
c'est ce qui vous avez envie de revenir
qui vous a donné envie de donc les
japonais ont déjà progressé disque en
plus ils se disent pro d'une tournée au
japon ok et
il ya le nougat dans ce disque et ça a
commencé vers un petit mot un petit
malheur le nougat et après moi je
j'ai continuéà site social et j'imagine
qui est pour moi une excellente maison
ok je suis ravi et je vais trois disques
la non trop 4
qui marche bien ouais bah c'est la
conclusion donc kékéland le morceau donc
le single c'est pipeau 1 et puis voilà
pipeau tournée en france comme je disais
et donc le 16 mai au bataclan voilà on a
fait le tour du problème un voyage
d'affaires est réglé je vous en prie
merci a bientot l'egypte et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais 1 pouces bleus